hey ben it's good to see you
um i have a short proposal for you and
then a question but um we have a
conservative musician group chat we all
study music oh my name's jonathan by the
way i study music at ubc
um and we all agree that you need a
better theme song for your show
okay
so you you want to commission us to play
it for you
okay so uh a couple of things about this
first of all you're 180 correct it is so
true okay
okay
this is the pro when you launch a
company you'll see this okay when you
boot your bootstrap yourself into
existence there's certain things that
just get carried along it's like
evolutionary holdovers and the guitar
riff at the beginning is that thing
right so what happened like here's the
back story on the guitar riff at the
beginning of my show so the show is
starting we're literally doing it from
jeremy bourne's pool house it was really
like me in a pool house with like a
couple of guys we were friends with and
no room and it was it's wild if you go
back and watch the first episode and you
see how far we've come it's pretty cool
um and
we wouldn't even have music the first
episode about three weeks in they hand
build that set you might anybody
remember the old set that had like the
boards in the back like the wooden
boards in the back right that was like a
couple of guys who we knew who literally
just went in one day and just nailed
together a bunch of boars and that was
the backdrop of my show and we realized
that we needed some
marker for the audio editors to cut
around right they needed some sort of
cue for the uh for the graphic to fly in
the problem was that licensing music is
super expensive and we were deeply
afraid that if we were to use unlicensed
music then it would get pulled down or
people on the left would you know own
the music and go crazy uh and by the way
talk radio has been living in this kind
of gray space for a while every time you
listen to talk radio and you hear a song
that you know uh that comes in from the
bumper they're basically living in a
very gray space in american law and
there's a very good shot that at some
point somebody's gonna sue for residuals
and it's getting super ugly so we
decided we weren't going to do that
instead we got jeremy boring's brother
will to literally go in a studio and
play a guitar for 35 seconds
okay and that became that riff
then they proposed to me several
alternatives none of them very good and
the problem is it's become pavlovian for
a lot of people right now they hear the
riff and they know that it's the show so
it's actually this this terrible guitar
riff has become part of the show almost
permanently so in other words for us to
shift that you'd have to blow my socks
off but i'm totally open for it like
do we have time for the other questions
always the other question the first one
is good so i'll give you all right all
right
um so i have a lot of
family that's you know undocumented
immigrants um and so i i see firsthand
you know how good you know these types
of people can can do for the country and
as we like in the present um 90 of the
people who are deported are
you know because they committed a crime
or something like that so technically we
kind of already have some sort of
amnesty if you will so i just wanted to
ask what
um your position is on on amnesty for
you know law-abiding citizens that have
been here you know 20-plus years or
something like that so my position on
amnesty is the same as my position on
immigration which is that if we have the
resources to analyze several hundred
million uh you know irs returns every
year then we have the resources to
analyze it on an individual level
whether people should stay or whether
they should go and we do this on
immigration all the time right if you're
a new immigrant then you have to go
through a process and we have to
determine whether we think you're going
to be good for the country or bad for
the country there are a lot of
undocumented immigrants who have been
living here for a really long time
illegal immigrants and and they did
immigrate illegally but that doesn't
mean the end of the world right i mean
that's a lot of people overstay their
visas a lot of people came through the
southern border have been very
productive citizens and would be
excellent additions to the country as
citizens and there are a lot of people
who have not it's up to the country to
decide essentially whether they should
stay or whether they should go i don't
think that presence in the country alone
is enough to demarcate whether somebody
should stay or go and i don't think
duration of presence in the country is
enough to demarcate whether somebody
should stay or or they should go so
criminality i don't think is the only
standard i think it's a very strong
standard if you commit a crime you
certainly should go but let's say that
you've been in the united states for a
long time you've been receiving you know
soft forms of welfare because some forms
of welfare ban some kind of through back
doors or not but let's say that you've
been sort of a net drain on on the
resources of the state or locality
if you've been here 30 years i don't
really care i don't think the united
states should continue to subsidize you
if you've been here working a job and
you've raised a family you should go to
the back of the line and then we should
analyze you and if you deserve to be
here and if you're going to be a net
addition to the united states then we
should
we should make a citizen we should give
you a pathway but it needs to be done in
an individual level and i'm always
puzzled when people do this on the basis
of sort of like an entire class of
people as though the country doesn't
have a stake in determining who comes in
the country right we shouldn't be doing
this as like entire group of people from
this age to this age who came in in this
year from this country should get to
stay i don't understand why it would
work that way we should be analyzing as
again i believe in seeing people as
individuals this is true of illegal
immigrants as well people who came here
illegally if you are a benefit to the
country you went to
a lot of so-called dreamers right people
who came in as children they went to
college they're now graduating from ucla
with a degree in engineering is it a
good idea for us to deport them i don't
think so
if somebody you know came as a child
you know hasn't been arrested for a
crime but dropped out of high school and
is now a member of a gang should we
deport them of course
it should be done on an individual level
as opposed to doing it just sort of as a
broad class and i think most americans
can get on board with this most
americans basically say shut the border
figure out what to do with the people
here right and it should be two separate
things it shouldn't be all in one
because you need to first shut the
border so you're not incentivizing
people to cross illegally more and then
you need to figure out what to do with
the people here but both parts are
required